one bottle el himador, 100% agave azul, cristalino, one bottle erradura, repasado, tequila, one
liter, one bottle erradura anejo, tequila, 750 milliliters, six bottles gearbox
pinot noir, two bottles windstorm cabernet, six bottles squealing pig, 13
bottles scarpetta pinot grigio, 11 bottles marque de caseres cava brut, three bottles
windstorm chardonnay, 12 bottles 30a chardonnay, eight bottles 30a rose, two
bottles carters lot rosé, 14 bottles canoe ridge merlot, 14 bottles
charles de fer brut, four bottles marque de caseres cava brut, 12 bottles charles
de fer brut, four bottles mojito, eight bottles margarita, ten bottles watermelon mix, three
six-packs of margarita mix, two six-packs of watermelon mix, seven four-packs high-rise
blueberry, eight four-packs high-rise pineapple, three 24-packs yingling, three 24-packs
Michelob,
five 12-packs athletic, one 12-pack Coors,
two 12-packs Pacifico, two 12-packs Miller Lite, two 24-packs of pineapple high noon,
four four-packs of pineapple high noon, one 24-pack Red Bull sugar-free, one four-pack
Red Bull sugar-free, one 24-pack Red Bull regular, another 24-pack of Red Bull regular,
three bottles blue agave natural sweetener, two bottles cream of coconut, eight bottles
strawberry puree, eight more bottles blue agave natural sweetener, five bottles Bloody Mary mix,
twelve bottles grenadine, nine bottles tahine, twenty-eight cans of ginger beer, five bottles
of angostura bitters, nine bottles Pueblo Viejo tequila, ten bottles Yave coconut tequila,
four bottles Casamigos Blanco, six bottles Siete Mestadios mezcal, six bottles Milagros
silver tequila, fourteen bottles Parrot Bay white rum, five bottles Parrot Bay coconut
rum, nine bottles Mr. Boston triple sec, four bottles Mr. Boston blue curacao, two bottles
one bottle Campesino silver rum, six bottles Caravella limoncello, four more bottles of Campesino
silver rum, two bottles Grand Marnier, eleven bottles of Bowls elderflower liqueur, one liter,
three bottles of Bowls elderflower liqueur 750 milliliters, nine bottles of rumple mints,
seven bottles Romana Amaro, two bottles crop organic cucumber vodka,
one more bottle of Mr. Boston triple sec, twelve one-liter bottles of crop organic cucumber vodka,
a quarter of a bottle of Yave coconut tequila, 75% of a bottle of Siete Mestadios mezcal,
one-third of a bottle of Pueblo Viejo, one-tenth of a bottle of Tito's, 60% of a bottle of Wheatley's,
10% of a bottle of Parrot Bay white rum, 25% of a bottle of crop organic cucumber vodka,
90% of a bottle of Jim Beam, 90% of a bottle of Parrot Bay coconut rum, five bottles of Crown Royal,
eight bottles of Meyer's original dark rum, two bottles of Maker's Mark, one bottle of Jim Beam,
one point eight bottles of Tullamore Dew, eight bottles of Fireball, 16 bottles of Jack Daniel's,
21 bottles of Mr. Boston peach schnapps, three bottles of Aperol, 2.6 bottles of Campari,
0.8 bottles of Romana Amaro, 90% of a bottle of Campesino silver rum, one bottle of Campesino
aged rum, 80% of a bottle of Campari, one bottle of Tia Maria cold brew coffee liqueur,
one more bottle of Tia Maria cold brew coffee liqueur, eight bottles of Wheatley's vodka,
one bottle of crop organic cucumber vodka, two bottles of Grey Goose, one liter, four bottles of Tito's,
five bottles of crop organic Meyer lemon flavored vodka, five bottles of Farmer's gin, nine bottles of Hendrick's gin,
seven bottles of Grand Gala orange liqueur, four bottles of Woodford Reserve, five bottles of Tankeray London dry gin,
ten bottles of Jägermeister,
one bottle Eridura Blanco original tequila, it comes in its own box,
the original tequila Eridura, 700 milliliters, Blanco, and then Eridura tequila Añejo, Barrio Acanalado, it's in a nice black box.